if you're
if you're authentic with who you are
goods and bads you will know how to
create what that is and for me
violence and fighting and conflict was
something that always felt
normal to me and i don't mean normal and
like i grew up in a war zone or a
abusive household or something like that
i just meant that and i was a kid who
was very
joyful and inquisitive
and spent a lot of time around older
people of all things
uh and also while i don't think i have
much
capability towards engineering my mom
said that one of the first things
as like a little baby when she put me in
my sister's old crib
instead of my sister who just milled
about and was fine with it all
the first thing i did was i completely
deconstructed it i didn't break it i
figured out how to pull it apart
curiosity about the world and yet that
wasn't in conflict with the idea of
violence
no not at all and so being a very joyful
and
nice kid but you know kids are kids and
and
if if kids can find that you
respond maybe more easily to
agitation they will agitate you and if
you should stand out in some way by
being taller or bigger or something
or caring especially they will agitate
you
they don't really fully understand it
either and so i don't i don't hold
anything against like any of kids that
used to pick on me or whatever
especially at the youngest stage just
like
man they don't know [ __ ] either so um
but once that line was pushed for me it
was
oh well i was i was being cool now
you're being uncool yeah
well then that gives me license for
everything and so boom we would just go
at it or kids that would try to initiate
a fight
okay and being in that moment of just
going going to town with someone else it
just felt like
this is this is i belong here yeah it
was it was never
a problem for me like the in fact if
anything
the over what i had to understand was
well not only did i learn the hard way
that it doesn't matter
at the end of the day it doesn't really
matter what anybody else does
if your response and violence
even to their violence if you're the
winner
is often going to be penalized severely
you know society state apparatus
they don't want any of that they want to
be the only arbiter of violence in the
world
always but i learned a very difficult
lesson with that and it was
really impactful in a negative way on me
but also i had to learn
on an individual sense to
you need to manage violence too because
hey if someone attacks you or
starts a fight with you and you go at it
okay beating them up is one thing
you know um you know trying to grab a
handful of broken glass from the street
and throw it in their face
maybe that's a bit much at seven
so you need to learn what what level
is necessary and you need to learn what
comes with
with all what's the responsibility of
when you enact violence i mean you take
on
something when you you have a
responsibility for that this is
the extension of your actions um so
uh but as i got older and especially as
i found
sports and then combat sports
now this was a place for me to flourish
and
to the point where i was more myself
in that space than i was outside of it
until time enough where i could learn to
to get this back together again and i
never say that i
that i'll merge the two or anything like
that no all
what happened my my uh
um my journey uh from adolescence
on to uh to manhood
a huge portion of it besides the normal
finding yourself whatever whatever
actually what it was was re getting back
to who i
always was getting that curious kid the
kind kid
getting back to the guy that i should
have been allowed to become
instead of what happened under the
pressures
of other things yeah and uh the
attempt for society and and
certain people within you know
managerial positions to
to compress what that was into something
that they found more suitable
you